Trascrizione: Ludovica Mucci
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Lo vedete questo simbolo?
Questo ideogramma cinese tradizionale:
una stessa parola che significa
sia musica che gioia.
D'altronde, questo accostamento
non ci è poi tanto lontano,
se pensiamo in quante
altre lingue e culture
suonare e giocare sono lo stesso verbo:
spielen, jouer, play.
Di nuovo un'analogia gioiosa.
Giocare, suonare: insomma, divertirsi.
Ma perché è proprio gioia,
la parola a cui accostiamo la musica?
È veramente solo così -
un gioco, un divertimento, un'allegria -
o c'è dell'altro?
Io suono il pianoforte
da quando avevo quattro anni:
È sicuramente la cosa più bella
che ho imparato a fare nella vita.
Ma riusciamo a renderci tutti conto
di quanto possa anche essere
duro, difficile e tormentato
il cammino di crescita
del piccolo musicista?
Disciplina, impegno,
sacrifici, enormi solitudini;
una pratica quotidiana
di esercizi estenuanti,
ripetizioni inesauste,
stress psicofisico a livello agonistico.
Sempre lì a perfezionare un gesto,
a controllare un suono,
a rilassare questo o quel muscolo.
Giorno dopo giorno, errore dopo errore.
Gioia?
Perché non chiamarla, anche,
fatica, sfida, sacrificio?
Perché poi esiste anche una fatica
molto più sottile, che non si vede,
ad accompagnare il percorso
di crescita dell'artista.
Sto parlando del cammino
che il musicista fa dentro di sé:
il cammino interiore,
alla ricerca della sua propria voce,
quella che gli serve per avere
sempre qualcosa da dire.
Comunicare un messaggio
grazie alla sua arte,
con il proprio talento.
Ma questo talento, che cos'è?
Sicuramente è un dono preziosissimo,
che ogni giorno dobbiamo
innaffiare, coltivare
con gratitudine, amore,
dedizione e costanza.
Ma il talento può anche essere un limite!
In qualche modo, segna
una linea - una demarcazione -
con tutta un'altra
grande fetta di umanità.
È come se il talento mettesse,
per una qualche specifica
dote, abilità, capacità,
degli umani oltre un confine,
in una sorta di comfort zone
dove alcune cose ci riescono meglio,
ci sono più facili, più naturali.
Però può capitare di sentirsi
veramente molto soli,
perché può capitare
di lasciare inesplorato
tutto quel vivere fatto, anche,
dei nostri tanti non talenti.
Tutto quello che siamo,
tutta la vita che abbiamo
oltre quel confine.
Allora, perché proprio gioia?
Perché non solitudine, tormento,
coraggio di andare oltre?
Ma andiamo a sentirlo nella musica stessa,
quella che è il risultato
di tanta ricerca e sforzo.
Come ci fa sentire, cosa ci fa provare?
Soltanto gioia? Qui sì!
(Musica)
Anche qui, allegria!
Ma qui?
(Musica)
Come vi sentite, come va?
È sempre Beethoven!
(Musica)
Oppure Rachmaninov.
Che diceva che la poesia
è la sorella della musica,
(Musica)
e la madre è la tristezza.
Ma quante altre emozioni,
quanti altri stati d'animo
può farci provare la musica?
Per esempio questo ostinato: Prokofiev.
(Musica)
O daquesta ossessione: Chopin.
Rabbia!
Ira!
Disperazione!
La pace.
Un momento di tranquillità.
Ci fa respirare.
Oppure, ci porta a ballare!
O un altro ballo!
Un valzer!
Angoscia.
Presagio.
Paura!
Oh, la quiete del sogno!
Dolce.
Che ci tiene sospesi.
Appesi a un filo.
O ancora, una cavalcata! Appassionata!
(Applausi)
Grazie, grazie.
Ma come vi sentite?
Come vi siete sentiti, cosa avete provato?
Vi sentite solo pieni
di allegria, contentezza, felicità,
o c'era dell'altro?
Quando nella vita,
ascoltando della musica,
come abbiamo fatto ora,
vi è capitato di commuovervi,
e vi sono scese delle lacrime,
erano lacrime di gioia o di dolore?
Il punto è che non importa.
Quello che conta è che la musica ci muove.
Non ha importanza
se quello che abbiamo ascoltato
ci è sembrato triste, agitato o infuocato.
Quello che conta è che
ci ha mosso qualcosa dentro,
che ci ha fatto vivere un'emozione.
E il fatto stesso che noi
la sentiamo passare, questa energia,
ci fa sentire vivi.
E in questo sentirci vivi,
vulnerabili, veri,
indipendentemente da quale sia
il nostro stato d'animo,
incominciamo a intravederla, la gioia,
che ci rende, finalmente,
liberi nel sentirci.
Perché la musica ha la grande capacità
di far provare delle emozioni
a chi la suona e a chi la ascolta.
Ci riconnette con noi stessi,
e ci fa sentire compresi.
Ci ricollega a noi stessi,
ci fa ricollegare
a qualche nostra fragilità,
ricordo del passato,
vulnerabilità del presente,
perché ci arriva così:
nell'aria, con i suoni,
con delle vibrazioni,
dagli strumenti musicali
fino ai nostri corpi.
Perché tutto ciò che vibra è vita.
Allora io voglio
raccontarvi adesso un aneddoto.
Nei miei tanti viaggi
ai confini del mondo,
oltre le frontiere
delle società civilizzate
e le barriere culturali e sociali,
mi è capitato di incontrare
tanti tipi di umani
di diverse etnie,
culture, età e religioni.
Ma quelli che mi sono sempre rimasti
più impressi nel cuore
sono sempre stati i bambini.
Che nella loro spontaneità
sono così limpidi, puri, sinceri.
Una volta mi trovavo
in una township sudafricana,
una sorta di favela in Sudafrica,
in una piccola scuola -
un centro dei diritti umani -
in un luogo molto povero,
dove l'Università di Port Elizabeth
aveva fatto arrivare un pianoforte.
Ovviamente, questi bambini
non avevano mai visto un pianoforte,
né avevano mai visto una ragazza come me
suonare della musica classica.
Non parlando la stessa lingua,
ci siamo capiti un po' a gesti,
un po' con delle preghiere;
ma soprattutto, anche con la musica.
Allora io cominciai a suonare
delle melodie semplici,
orecchiabili, divertenti;
e poi, per tranquillizzarli
un po', per calmarli,
suonai loro la ninna nanna
di Brahms: questa.
(Musica)
Vabbè, la conosciamo tutti - ma loro no!
Loro non l'avevano mai sentita.
La cosa incredibile
è che dal suono solitario del pianoforte
questi bambini si misero
a cantare in coro, felici,
una loro cantilena, una canzone popolare
che secondo loro faceva proprio
come il Wiegenlied di Johannes Brahms.
Finalmente gli era sembrato di riconoscere
che cosa stava suonando per loro.
Allora io li continuai
ad accompagnare, suonare con loro.
(Musica)
Perché questi tipi di canti così semplici,
armonicamente accessibili,
sono uguali in tutto il mondo.
Nella loro semplicità cullano,
abbracciano tutti,
senza limiti, senza confini.
E così, anche grazie
a questa esperienza così dolce,
mi è sembrato di cominciare a capire
come mai così tante culture
associano nel loro linguaggio,
nella loro scrittura,
il concetto di musica a quello di gioia.
Ma proviamo a fare
anche tanti altri esempi:
i canti di montagna; l'inno nazionale;
il coro della chiesa;
le canzoni da stadio;
la radio alta in macchina
con gli amici in vacanza;
cantare sotto la doccia;
le preghiere con la nonna;
il karaoke; il rosario mariano;
i mantra; le prove con la band;
cantare; ballare;
divertirsi tutti insieme
a un concerto o in discoteca.
Forse la gioia è proprio quella
che, grazie alla musica,
ci rende parte di un tutto.
Dissolvendo delle resistenze,
delle densità,
oltrepassando dei confini
improvvisamente ci fa trovare
quel qualcosa che ci riunifica.
E quando la musica riesce
a spezzare tutto questo,
noi non ci sentiamo più soli.
Non solo siamo vivi
e vibriamo delle emozioni,
ma anche cantiamo e risuoniamo
di un coro universale.
E quando la musica ci riesce,
e ci unisce in questo modo,
noi ci sentiamo abbracciare
un respiro più ampio,
ci sembra di continuare un qualcosa
nella voce, negli occhi,
nelle mani degli altri.
Non le ho ordinate io le campane, però -
In questo passaggio di energia,
facendo passare questa libertà vibrante
che chiamiamo musica,
ci ritroviamo addosso un qualcosa
a cui non saprei dare il nome più esatto:
gioia.
(Applausi)